YouTube♪ YouTube♪ Broadcast Yaeh!
（YouTubeテーマソング　ヒカキン＆セイキン）
youtube大好きやん
はい！　こんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです！
はい。というわけで、今回は再び弟が来てくれました　どうぞー！
まあ、とりあえずまあ、飲んでください
まあ、とりあえず、まあ飲んでみな
シュー(炭酸が抜ける音)
前回、弟が来てくれたとき、反響がすごかった。
兄弟のそういうの見たかったーみたいな
やつがまた来てたんで、ちょっと、第二弾もやろうというわけでございます！
自己紹介
たける）自己紹介？
はじめ）自己紹介だよほら、初めて見る人もいるかもしれないから
たける）あー
えっと、弟の、ピー(効果音)　たけるです
はじめ）まだ、本名またやめとけよ
昨日さ、飯食いに行ってたときさ、言ってたじゃないですか。
まだ俺は、兄貴の伝説の話があるみたいな
たける）いや、それはいくらでもあるでしょ
はじめ）なんなの、ちょっとじゃー俺のまだ過去に眠る、我々の伝説の話を今日はしよう。
子供のころに、なんかこうやばかったみたいな、なんかこう、なんかなかったっけ
たける）牛角に行ってたの、覚えてる
はじめ）あー。焼肉屋さんね。俺たちの地元の。
たける）あのときにさ、勉強しに行ったやん。
兄貴が勉強に行こうぜって言ってさ、図書館に行ってさ、勉強して、昼飯食いに行こうっつって、
牛角に行って、
行ったときに（笑）
はじめ）なつかしいな
たける）なんかお金なかったから、中学生と、高校生
はじめ）あ、そうだったね。中、高だったもんね
たける）どうしても、なんか安く焼肉を食べるために、
水しか飲むなみたいな
たけるお前、水しか飲むなよって言われて
で、牛角行って、座って、もうずっと言われとったんやって
お前絶対水しか飲むなよ、飲むなよってもうめっちゃ念を押されて
はじめ）あ、一緒に行ってたもんね
あ、なんか、言ってたんですよ、おれも。
お金ないから、肉をたくさん食べたいから、水しか飲まないでおこうっって
たける）飲み物はマジであれぼったくりだからみたいな
でいって、店員さんがすって来て、まあまあかわいい店員さんで
兄貴が超高速で、オレンジジュースでって言ってから
それでもう、あったよね。そういうことも。
覚えてる？
はじめ）覚えてます。それはもう…
なんかなかったっけ、まだ
あ、こうすけが公園で腕折ったとき？
たける）そうそうそうそう
はじめ）あー、あったね。
たける）あんときなんか兄貴、はやし立てるだけはやし立てて、なにもしなかったみたいな
はじめ）なんで俺、そんなことしたっけ？
俺が？
あのとき、どんなやった？
いや、俺は、あのときこうすけと遊んでなかったよ、ちなみに
たまたま行ったらこうすけが腕折っとって
で、寝とったから、うあ、やばい
と、ちょっとはやし立てて
はやし立てたってどういう意味？
はやし立てたってどういう意味？（二度目）
うあ、やれよみたいな
おれそん…
まじまじ止めたから。
ところでこうすけも言ってたからね
あれ、でも小学校のころ、ちんこ出してなかったっけ？
だしてたよ
学校でちんこ出して走り回ってたけど（笑）
だってこれ彼女にさ
知られたくないんだけど
そうですね
兄貴が小６の時に、
あんとき、たぶん…
ちょっと
ま、ちょっと、興味はあった。
多少エロスが
多少エロスはあった
家族の共用のパソコンが一階にあったよね
居間の一階にあったパソコン使ってエロフラッシュを見とったよんね
てか、兄貴なんかもう、そういうのやり始めたら
とりあえず俺に紹介するみたいな
たける見ろよみたいな
うん、たける見ろよみたいな
そういうとこあったよね
エロいのやっぱ、共有したかったんだよね
で、俺に言ってきて、エロフラッシュ
兄貴が見てるの俺に言うじゃん
たけるこれ見ろよみたいな
で、見せてくるやん
で見て、俺は何かわからない。そん時、
何歳だっけ、あの時
小２とか
小２か
俺の知らない世界が広がっているよ、そこには
兄貴が見せてきたところには
なんだこれみたいな
でなったから、とりあえず母さんに報告しようと思って
かあさーん（叫ぶ）
て言って、言いに来たら
まあ、兄貴がみせたその
まあまあエロ、エロ、まあかわいらしいけど
エロいやつがピーって流れてて
静かに母さんが俺ら二人に
やめとかれみたいな
軽めにしとかはれみたいな
言って帰ってったよね
あんとき確か、兄貴ちょろっと泣いてたで
めっちゃ、めっちゃ
いや、たけるやめろよみたいな
マジでやめろって
あったよね
あったね
どうすかたけるさん
好きなYoutuberは？
好きなYoutuber
好きなYoutuber？
ピー（効果音）
ばか！マジでこれはマジ
燃え尽きちゃった
はい、というわけで僕の弟がまた家に来ましたという動画でした
またいつでも来ておくれ
という訳で何かメッセージを
愛してるよ
バチン！！！